bonsoir monsieur jeudi 15 octobre merci
de nous retrouver pour cette nouvelle
édition du 7 8 le journal on commence
tout de suite avec les titres de votre
actualité locale
les audits de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines révèle de graves
dysfonctionnements c'est en substance la
conclusion présenté par la nouvelle
majorité cette semaine l'opposition de
gauche s'en défend le point en plateau
avec le premier vice président en charge
de l'économie à la casse qui jean michel
fourgous et le président de promo paul
pépinière d'entreprises
othman nassr où le candidat tête de
liste du front de gauche en
ile-de-france pierre laurent était à
l'université aujourd'hui pour évoquer
son programme le fond gauche crédité
d'un peu moins de 10% des intentions de
vote dans les sondages
et puis la guerre des multiplexes se
poursuit dans le département maurepas à
coignières le chesnay-versailles plaisir
les projets se multiplient
de quoi inquiéter les salles existants
qui n'hésitent pas à déposer de nombreux
recours et nous déplorons que cette
polémique autour des finances de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines la majorité a tenu mardi une
conférence de presse pour évoquer les
audits commandés sur la gestion de la
précédente équipe et les accusations
portées sont lourdes
bonsoir jean michel fourgous premier
vice-président de la communauté
d'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines et maire les républicains
d'elancourt et bonsoir othmana through
président du conseil d'administration de
promo paul pépinière d'entreprises est
également chef de file les républicains
de l'opposition à trappes
on saura également à vous wilfrid vous
avez rejoint pour cette séquence et
c'est avec vous que nous débutons
bonsoir florane bonsoir messieurs une
première précision en introduction tout
de même pour les téléspectateurs puisque
nous avons convié sur ce plateau elle
sandrine grand gaube la responsable de
l'opposition socialiste à
l'agglomération la responsable du ps
dans les yvelines elle n'a pas souhaité
participer son explication la voici
résumée en un tweet posté ce matin on me
somme de débattre sur des documents que
je n'ai pas et elle a ensuite ajouté le
débat cette arme égale sinon c'est une
tribune pour manipulateur et menteur ton
donner bien évidemment ma première
question est pour vous jean michel
fourgous ces différents documents que
vous évoquez ces audits sont elles
public est en tout cas on peut l'être
communiqué vont-ils être communiquées
ces différents résultats a senti un
grand grand bal opposition aujourd'hui
socialiste écoutez il ya d'abord les
documents dont nous parlons sont les
documents publics que madame grand g
connais très bien
pour l'essentiel je veux dire qu'il n'ya
pas de surprise à la réponse de normand
bon voilà elle elle refuse elle trouve
des subterfuges pour éviter de rendre
des comptes après 42 ans d'abus dans
cette intercommunalité de où ils ont
bloqué toute démocratie puisqu'il n'y a
pas eu d alternance pendant quarante
deux ans et ça c'est quelque chose les
élections t non mais justement le jeu
des élections c'est qu'il a il aurait
fallu qu'une élection pourquoi est-ce
qu'il ya pas eu d alternance ça veut
dire que les élections étaient pipés
quelque part ça veut dire que quand vous
avez une armée vous entretenez une armée
de près de 100 personnes entre la caisse
qui les satellites et les associations
forcément comment voulez vous attend est
égal que les votes ont été achetés quel
est donc là on sent même du cadre les
otites sans accusation lourde mais elle
n'est pas sur des mots nous nous voulons
maintenant j'essaie de ce coffret on se
contente de constater voilà vous avez
vous avez un 10 recrutements qui ne
respecte pas le principe de deux il ya
des recrutements et des gens très
compétents la caisse qui mais vous en
avez pour 20% dès gens qui sont rentrés
sur d'autres critères que la compétence
c'est soit la proximité politique soit
le lait est le fils de la soeur de le
cousin la belle-fille le beau-fils le
voilà je pense que ce n'est pas conforme
à l'esprit républicain ce n'est pas
conforme à l'éthique
ce n'est pas conforme et puis recruté
des gens les promouvoir ou les former
sur d'autres critères que le mérite les
résultats ou les forces et c'est
inacceptable
mais les différents traits moselle qui
j'en suis assis dans la casse qui parce
que les gens voient 80% des gens vont
aider des gens qui arrivent on ne
comprend pas pourquoi ils ont des
promotions comprends pas pourquoi des
aventures on va y arriver là ça sur le
fond c'est de là qu'est tout le monde
paul et le moment que j'aurais aimé
qu'elle me réponde
est ce que oui ou non elle a constaté
les auditeurs sont retransmises ne
respectent pas les transmettrai elles
ont été transmises
ces audits ont été transmises à elles
seront transmises tous les élèves bien
sûr que nous on n'a rien à cacher
visiblement en tout cas ça n'a pas l'air
d'être stress mental et shana nombre de
venir débattre avec nous alors
d'informations officielles est simple
puisque nous l'avons juste avant de
passer en plateau ce soir elle a accepté
le fait de venir en plateau une fois
qu'elle aurait les éléments et une fois
qu elle l aurait tout loisir ensuite de
répondre sur les accusations précises
qui sont portés on va résumer brièvement
quelques-unes des accusations que vous
avez déjà commencé à aborder embauche
familiale et partisane train de vie
dispendieux par exemple l'utilisation
d'hélicoptères pour se rendre sur une
étape du tour de france
ça ce sont des éléments qui sont
vérifiées il ya une véracité dont les
éléments vous affirmer ça ressort
concrètement c'est écrit dans les audits
vous avez des des ordres de mission
signée du président
en voyant un élu de la caisse qui
voilà utilisé des hélicoptères en saut
de puce en plus que déjà un hélicoptère
mais un saut de puce c'est bon voilà je
vois pas très bien ce qui peut négocier
une façon aussi on a ou des voyages à
ouagadougou très bien où il veut du goût
mais quel est le rapport avec avec le
travail de la communauté enfin sans
cesse et des voyages et des voyages
insensés f1 un descriptif mesures qui
sont à l'heure où il ya 6 million et
demi de jeunes gens qui n'ont plus
d'emploi dans ce pays en france dans
toute la france toutes catégories
c'est insupportable d'avoir des gens qui
n'ont aucune culture économique parce
que visiblement ce laisser-aller de
telles dérives ou à des telles
recrutement ou ait de tels jeux dire
quand quand par exemple il il ne finance
pas la principale compétence qui est
obligatoire quel développement
économique et que l'on met 30 fois plus
de moyens sur une autre de compétences
ce que le e lors leur fascination c'est
la culture c'est la communication
il y avait quarante quatre personnes la
communication de la caisse qui il n'y a
pas une entreprise en it dans les
yvelines qui est un service de
communication avec 44 collaborateurs et
je peux vous dire il ya des entreprises
comme airbus comme thales comme guillon
caen 1 1 autre résultat pour la france
que que que l'interco très politisé
qu'on avait auparavant nous voilà il ya
des choses qui sont inaccessibles à des
choses qui se relève être illégal qui
relève du domaine de la justice
est ce que vous allez engager des
procédures ou écoutez moi je fais
totalement confiance à la justice
il ya des éléments effectivement qui
sont très préoccupants d'une certaine
gravité et de toute façon à partir du
moment où on avait fait un audit où il
fallait pas le faire on a on a
connaissance de ces informations nous de
façon de les transmettre à la justice
pas un problème de choix ou pas il est
légal
est ce que la nouvelle majorité de la
communauté d'agglomération va engager
des poursuites sur certains points très
précis qui relève de l'illégalité
écoutez on est des avocats qui
travaillent là dessus qui effectivement
nous nous ont donné aussi parce que mon
nez en étant en connaissance de centres
d'information on doit lui rendre
on doit les transmettre à la justice on
voit là nous on se contente de cela ce
sera la justice ensuite de trancher et
de faire des poursuites
je crois que par exemple il ya comme une
présomption de 2,2 de favoritisme de qui
comme assez évidente la 2e 52 de choses
qui sont d'une gravité juridique prise
illégale d'intérêt par exemple les élus
allemands puisque l'opposition évoque
des documents qui seraient
potentiellement faut éventuellement il
se réserve aussi le droit de les
attaquer en justice donc on sera devant
les tribunaux je vous rappelle que le ps
a dit exactement la même chose
suite elle nous dit dans l'essonne idem
dans le val d'oise à chaque fois ils
disent c'est faux tout est faux ou de ce
sont la technique du mensonge est
quelque chose qui qui est dans la
culture du parti socialiste française
pas des autres participants vous avez le
dernier parti marxiste qui est en france
le dernier le pays qui utilise des
techniques marxiste avec le ps est en
france et à chaque fois c'est la même
chose ces gens c'est ce pour eux c'est
celui qui ment le plus qui gagne et
c'est dans les gènes la crise qui sait
la justice j'ai dit ça qu'il faut mais
justice va dire que la justice qui peut
trancher puisque elle reprend en parlant
d' audit voilà justement il ya le cadre
de peu de promo pépinière d'entreprises
qui est financé par l'agglomération et
qui a aussi fait l'objet d'un audit
autres malades nassr où vous aviez donc
lancé un audit lors de la prise de vos
fonctions en 2014 après le changement de
majorité à l'agglomération il avait
révélé une dette d'à peu près 2 6
millions d'euros vous aviez découvert la
faillite si on peut parler ainsi la
pépinière des veaux prise de fonction
weir affections c'était premier roddick
a porté la nouvelle majorité puisque
vont se prend paul est une société de
droit privé donc on peut aller plus vite
évidemment là dessus dans cet audit
audit est arrivé un peu à la rentrée
2014 pour être précis et à l'époque on
avait tout mis sur la table on avait
tout dit d'ailleurs je me suis étonné
que jamais personne n'a répondu aux
aussi là aussi aux accusations lourdes
sur ce dossier provoque walkie
emblématique des dysfonctionnements de
cette agglomération et voyez là
aujourd'hui on a une indignation un
petit peu de l'ancienne majorité
socialiste mais sur ce dossier là je
n'ai jamais eu de réponse ici aussi les
ai pas envie d'organiser personnel
comprendre des coupes promosport et est
ce que vous savez pas comment cela a pu
être dissimulées commence à ce que vous
aviez découvert ça justement seulement à
votre prise de fonction pas que c'est le
propre d'une alternance effectivement
vous avez une agglomération qui aussi
été caractérisée gestion qui était
caractérisé par l'opacité
voilà donc on découvre je dirais qu'ils
savaient précisément que le directeur de
profopol touché près de 8000 euros par
mois
alors que cette structure dans une
situation de quasi faillite qui a pris
cette décision ce n'est pas à moi ce
n'est pas nous fera que c'est la
précédente majorité il est normal
qu'elles viennent rendre des comptes
aujourd'hui là dessus moi j'entends que
l'on traite de menteur et c'est là c'est
une information qui factuelle ou je dis
la vérité où je mens et si je dis la
vérité
il faut que ceux qui en sont
responsables s'explique faut quand même
les gens ont le droit de savoir ce qu'on
fait de leur argent et ce propos paul
ferme emblématique je donne cet exemple
là je peux en donner d'autres
le fils du président il a été embauché
oui ou non c'est aussi simple là dessus
d'une question peut-être sur le timing
parce que vous l'avez dit par exemple
cet audit sur promo paul a été dévoilée
en tout cas les résultats ont été rendus
il ya déjà quelques mois la conférence
de presse que vous avez organisé
c'était en tout début de semaine dans
quelques semaines ya les élections
régionales
vous êtes le porte parole de valérie
pécresse par exemple dont dans les
yvelines pour pour sa liste sandrine
granby elle figure sur la liste du côté
du parti socialiste on est dans le cadre
de la campagne électorale et que c'est
sur une grande banque qui a dit
justement que c'était une ficelle pour
les élections régionales c'est de faire
un parallélisme entre la gestion de
l'agglomération aujourd'hui la gestion
de la région
je lui laisse cette responsabilité là et
le baril pourquoi mx sur ses préférences
j'avais une toile et les nous sommes là
depuis un peu plus d'un an oui il faut
on a lancé 5,5 audit il ya
l'élargissement à gérer bon nous le
dernier rapport on l'a eue le 25
septembre
c'est la partie ressources humaines de
toute façon le temps de faire la
compilation de tout ça c'est très lourd
et donc voilà on a commencé à en parler
donc début octobre
il n'y a rien de veiller de
machiavélique là dedans puisque vous
apporter différentes réponses je vous
redonner la parole juste après on va
l'écouter
sandrine grande langue avec les
représentants de la gauche ils ont tenu
une contre conférence de presse au
lendemain de la montre on est dans une
stratégie assez classique où on veut
nous entraîner sur un terrain malsain
dans un des polémiques à ces caniveaux
en
mais dans une logique de diversion pour
éviter les vrais sujets les vrais sujets
c'est ce et qui prend aujourd'hui
l'ascendant au niveau de cette
agglomération entre plusieurs
personnalités politiques cirque on jeudi
de manière assez triviale mais on a
aujourd'hui d'aider des hommes en
carence qui se marquent à la culotte
pour savoir qui derrière au mois de
janvier va réussir à en ayant joué à
suffisamment des coudes à s'imposer pour
être le futur président de l'agglo c'est
ça l'enjeu qui est derrière ce genre de
problématique
c'est là visiblement clair il ya un jeu
entre des attaques et bien sûr lorsqu'on
a mis les cultes et évoquer ses seins
c'est une guerre entre vous et michel
laugier pour être transparent sûr qu'il
va prendre la tête de l'agglomération
1er janvier il passe de guerin et lâcher
le jeu sera vécue chez laugier voilà on
sait dans les réunions on peut être
regardée accord comme vous lis sur une
réaction a été le prince que tel sujet
oh la la c'est tout mais je m'entends
bien qu'il ya une chaîne logique mais
cela dit ce n'est pas une guerre des
chefs jour la mère est évoqué mais il ya
des différences entre eux mais on est on
demain on sera 12 on aura des débats et
si ya pas de débat c'est c'est un régime
totalitaire
c'est par un régime totalitaire on est
on débat librement démocratiquement faut
pas confondre débat avec voilà coutu je
crois que monsieur valls a dit encore
récemment il ya 24 heures que fallait
que le ps arrête de se déchirer
bon je pense que la madame grande
devrait peut-être répondre là-dessus
déjà qu'elle voit dans le chai elle
comment ça se passe l'union en ce moment
1 1
ce que ça ça être attrape que ce soit au
niveau national ce niveau régional
plutôt que viennent nous embêter là
dessus mais on n'a pas de problème
particularisme 70 instant elle n'aurait
pas sur le fond ça vaille vraiment une
pirouette on a parlé de faits assez
précis d'une gestion personnellement
quand il dit caniveau enfin je veux dire
quand même vous avez des gens qui
dirigent si j'ai un gérant gérer une
structure comme propofol qui ont laissé
la situation décrite qui est connue
depuis un petit moment quand même quand
on dit deux mois des régionales ce
moment je suis venu sur ce plateau qui
souhaitent sûrement pas dit oui mais
c'était sur les minerais pour vider des
accents la théorie des actions
judiciaires
son grand oui oui et on ira au bout
enfin si on ira au bout mais génial sur
ce dossier là comme sur le reste
mais j'aimerais bien qu'à un moment à
l'autre s expliquer ce qu'elle était en
cours est ce que c'est normal que voilà
cette structure-là est financé par
lampard mais en parlant de gestion des
menaces roulage ans la joueuse notation
standard and poor dans son rapport du 12
juillet 2015 attribue un a+ en note à
long terme à moins haute à court terme
et dit que les perspectives sont sales
sont stables concernant donc
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines et ne révèlent pas de défauts
dans l'historique comment vous
l'expliquez ce qui est justement un
décalage entre ce rapport de standard
and poor's et les défauts dans
l'hystérie dans l'histoire ce que dit
surtout c'était j'en sais que simplement
il ya une nouvelle équipe qui vient plus
du monde économique que l'ancien je
rappelle que l'ancien directeur du
développement économique était
professeur des écoles je crois c'est ça
bon ça c'est normal
qu'est-ce que ça à voir avec le
développement économique du secteur
marchand cette remarque dont voilà le e
cette agence a été très rassuré c'est
pour ça qu'ils font cette observation
n'a gagné que là-dessus donc voilà ils
sont rassurés de voir qu'il est une
nouvelle équipe qui qui s'engagent dans
le dans le désendettement c'était par
exemple sont des la biomédecine seligman
ancienne équipe comme avec l'ancienne
équipe
les notes d'évaluation standard zen pour
ses autres été plutôt bonne concernant
l'agglomération de 50 ans nue mais oui
mais elle est têtue domaine parce que il
évalue des éléments qui sont qui sont
bons qui sont ceux qui sont leurs
critères qui sont sur mini ils
n'évaluent pas dans ta dans la même
lancée en mai l'ensemble des procédures
l'ensemble du personnel sont des
millions ça peut paraître la réserve le
changement de de compétences ils sont
pas des spécialistes et interco dire que
non ils vous regardent un certain nombre
de facteurs économiques mais qui ne sont
pas les audits le monde a lancé cinq
audit sur l'ensemble des domaines pour
gérer durablement une structure de 5 400
millions de dettes sans parler de
l'intérêt de la dette
vous êtes comme on est quand même des
intercoms les plus endettés y'a pas de
quoi voyager avec madame brand mais ce
qu'elle conteste ce tableau il est déjà
été rendues publiques
la sks qu'être qu'elle est ce qu'elle
est comment s'est-il on a les chiffres
vous inquiétez pas les éleveurs et
comment ça se fait qu'il ya deux tiers
des investissements qui étaient sur la
bonne jambe sur ce type de document
la réponse qu'elle vous ferai peut-être
pouvoir y répondre la rapidement parce
qu'on va être pris par le temps mais
c'est sur quelle période
elle dit ça manque de précision
lorsqu'elle voit ces documents
l'appareil c'est simplement la somme
c'est la somme des investissements qui
sont encore à rembourser
si vous rêvez tous les émissions qui
sont encore à rembourser vous les avez
pour les sept communes où vous avez
simplement apprendre les trois communes
de deux de droite et les quatre communes
de gauche ils ont à peu près le même
nombre d'habitants
il vous comparez et la somme ces deux
tiers-un tiers dans les équipements
communaux
on a dit oui les caisses publiques parce
que là je te tiens par exemple ils vous
ont fait du bien parce que ça ils sont
très fort là dessus et vous disent oh
attention vous avez vu montigny a plein
de mai ils ont mis la gare de montigny
c'est pour essayer de truquer le truc
comme d'habitude il est dehors tricher
et ça c'est en fait c'est culturel des
tricheurs bien on espère tenir à
l'occasion faire un débat justement son
plateau de la carte et un équipement
intercommunal c'est pas un équipement
commune donc je vous parle des
équipements communaux les igloos
communaux voilà le choix c'est on a 30
quand on a 30 euros dans une commune de
droite un habitant bain dans une commune
de gauche vous avez sur une diderot
c'est totalement injuste et madame dans
donc elle va m'expliquer effectivement
les procédures judiciaires parce qu'on
l'a bien compris d'un côté comme de
l'autre il devrait y en avoir en tout
cas wilfrid et en politique toujours
pierre laurent secrétaire national du
parti communiste est tête de liste front
de gauche aux prochaines régionales en
île de france était à l'université de
versailles saint quentin sur le site de
guyancourt il venu ce midi afin
d'échanger autour de la situation des
universités et de s'interroger sur les
solutions à adopter face aux
restrictions budgétaires
une manière d'attaquer frontalement
valérie pécresse candidate les
républicains dans la région et surtout à
l'origine de la loi d'autonomie des
universités
lors de son passage au gouvernement
le monde de l'université aujourd'hui
frappée doublement à la fois par les
politiques d'austérité qui frappe
l'ensemble des politiques publiques
et en même temps elle subit les
conséquences directes de la loi mis en
place par pécresse qui avait prétendu qu
en accordant l'autonomie de financement
et de gestion des universités une voie
royale allait s'ouvrir vers des moyens
nouveaux pour l'université et
aujourd'hui on sait que ça aboutit à la
mise en difficulté très profonde de
toute une série d'université en ile de
france et ailleurs et on assiste à des
regroupements universitaires qui pose
beaucoup de problème du point de vue de
la qualité de l'enseignement de
l'encadrement des étudiants au delà de
la vision aussi qu'on a deux des
contenus d'enseignement et puis alors un
également un sénateur s'est ensuite
rendu au palais du luxembourg dans
l'après-midi pour interpeller manuel
valls sur la situation des salariés
d'air france
enfin sachez que l'entretien complet
avec pierre laurent sera à retrouver
dans quelques jours sur notre antenne
pour le set vite politique
combien de cinéma vous voir le jour dans
notre région la question devrait être
tranchée dans les prochaines semaines
pour le moment le projet de complexe de
huit salles au village des loisirs de
maurepas et bien engagé celui du
multiplexe de coignières a été retoqué
en commission nationale d'aménagement
commercial à six voix contre une
alors que du côté du chesnay ou encore
de versailles de nombreux projet de
multiplexe et de rénovation de salles
sont en discussion le point avec fanny
bourdon entre mort pas equal hier la
guerre des cinémas est déclarée chaque
ville a son projet de multiplexe les
seulement l'un des deux pourra voir le
jour
la question semble avoir été tranchée
mercredi dernier en faveur de maurepas
lors de la commission nationale
d'aménagement commercial
moi je suis venu évidemment défendre le
projet du cinéma ne mord pas qu'ils
aient un intérêt tout particulier
puisqu'il se situe dans une zone
d'activité qui s'appelle village des
loisirs et qui a besoin justement d'un
nouveau souffle d'un nouveau dynamisme
au travers de ce cinéma alors que celui
qui est situé sur la ville de coignières
finalement on n'est pas un enjeu de
territoire puisque si le cinéma ne se
fait pas elle ne se fera pas cela ne met
pas en danger
finalement la zone d'activités de
coignières huit salles 1700 fauteuil et
une quinzaine d'emplois sont en jeu
les travaux pour
débuté dès le premier semestre 2016 ce
qui rendrait incompatibles le projet de
multiplexe de coignières effectivement
il est difficile de faire coexister deux
cinémas ce qui ferait un total de 3000
places environ et 18 salles c'est ça me
parait effectivement les deux complexes
on sont à 800 m 1 km de distance et donc
à la très grande proximité le la zone de
chalandise est la même dans le reste de
la région les projets de cinéma ne
manquent pas aux chaînés rappelez-vous
le cinéma de cinq salles sur le parking
de parler d'eux a fermé ses portes en
juin 2014
depuis le groupe ugc voudrait restaurer
ce cinéma pour un multiplexe de neuf
salles ce qui n'est pas du goût du maire
de versailles qui a lui aussi un projet
de multiplexe du groupe cgr non loin de
parler d'eux on a prévu qu'il y ait un
multiplexe de neuf salles seulement
qu'ils soient au coeur de la ville
c'est à dire entre l'avenue de saint
cloud et la nulle part comment le lieu
idéal parce que permet fernaj onction
entre les quartiers
normalement la commission départementale
a donné son accord
il devrait pas y avoir de problème
particulier avec quoi lierre mort pas le
chesnais et versailles
pas moins de quatre projet de multiplexe
sont en cours dans la région
de quoi inquiéter les petits cinémas de
quartier à l'image du ciné 7 d'elancourt
classé art et essai est composé de trois
salles la direction n'a pas souhaité
répondre à nos questions
car elle a actuellement déposé deux
recours contre les projets de multiplexe
de ces villes voisines
le cinéma craint une forte baisse de sa
fréquentation
aujourd'hui jeudi 15 octobre se déroule
le coworking partie en france dans 90
espace qui propose des bureaux à
partager une journée portes ouvertes
pour les entrepreneurs et les curieux
qui souhaitent découvrir les vertus de
ce concept né aux états unis
sephora namani et camille lambert se
sont rendus dans une autre prise de
coworking à saint quentin en yvelines
pour une heure une semaine leur bureau
c'est ici dans cette société de cauwer
king à guyancourt
ils travaillent à leur compte en
freelance mais pratiquer son activité
professionnelle de chez soi a parfois
les inconvénients
alors ils ont opté pour ce concept de
bureau à partager explication qu'on mord
king est une culture du travail la
culture de l'ue partagent fait sur le
terrain donc on n'est pas dans les idées
on n'est pas dans la théorie on est dans
l'action entrepreneurs start-up
professions libérales et
télétravailleurs sont les premières
cibles du coworking un moyen pour eux de
rompre l isolement de développer un
réseau ou de mutualiser des moyens
techniques et humains
c'est un vieux qui m'a permis de
rencontrer toutes les personnes avec des
compétences complémentaires unes des
autres pour pouvoir mais des as dans
cette dans ce projet dans cette
construction
chaque jeudi tous les quinze jours en
fait on fait une réunion de chefs
d'entreprise heures celui ci est donc
déjà à travers ça donc ça m'a permis de
rencontrer plusieurs plusieurs personnes
en plusieurs prostituées
le coworking c'est un peu les avantages
du travail en entreprise avec la liberté
d'être à son compte
un concept qui commence à peine à se
développer en france en 2014 environ dix
mille personnes s'était déjà essayée au
coworking
et comme chaque jeudi les temps de
retrouver la chronique sport avec notre
journaliste sportif à mickaël millero
bonsoir muté à la soif logram alors les
vacances scolaires débutent demain pour
de nombreux parents ses deux semaines
sont souvent un casse tête
on ne sait pas comment occuper ses
enfants moi je vais vous proposer des
idées de sorties sportives à faire en
famille tout d'abord il y aura un match
très important ce dimanche à 15 heures
entre trappe et villepinte en football
au stade gilbert gensac pour le parler
de cet événement nous recevons sur ce
plateau samba cissokho le jeune
attaquant trappistes bonsoir samba sort
alors ce match contre villepinte
est ce que c'est un match très important
pour la suite du championnat je pense
que c'est un match très important pour
la suite du championnat
tout d'abord dit en être sur trois
matches sans victoire
on est sur une bonne dynamique ensuite
c'est un match décisif à la fois parce
que c'est un les deux autres équipes ils
s'affrontent semaine prochaine et vous
disiez vous êtes sur trois victoires en
trois matches qu'est ce qui fait la
force de trappes cette année comparé aux
années précédentes c'est le travail
cette année on a repris tous ensemble on
avait un bon groupe
il y avait pratiquement tout le monde à
l'entraînement et il ya une bonne
ambiance aussi dans l'équipe très bonne
ambiance dans l'équipe comme on s'entend
bien
je pense que c'est ça qui fait notre
force je pense que ça va nous emmener
dans l'année et le coach mafia là aussi
est ce que est ce que c'est l'homme de
la situation
finalement sur pour pour la montée cette
année
wesley situation bien sûr si les qui
fait les choix il met ses équipes en
place
mais les remplaçants qui joue pas sur le
terrain quand ils s'arrêtent faire le
boulot
vous même vous êtes en très grande forme
en ce début de saison vous avez marqué à
tous les matchs si je me trompe pas tous
les matches tous les matches qu'est ce
qui explique votre votre forme actuelle
c'est le travail le travail ou à la
maison je travaille à l'entraînement je
me donne à fond
des fois on fait des heures
supplémentaires aux entraînements et
vous jouer ce week-end à domicile au
stade gilbert chance à qu'est ce que
vous voulez faire de ce stade une
forteresse imprenable y en a un bon
public je pense que c'est ça qui nous
porte vers l'avant et une forteresse si
on peut lui
il faut viser clairement la montée cette
année à monter vonn a d'autres on va
essayer d'aller plus loin possible en
coupe mais la priorité c'est la montée
merci à vous d'être passé sur ce plateau
bon courage pour le match de ce dimanche
donc je le rappelle le match est
programmé ce dimanche à 15 heures au
stade gilbert gensac beaucoup d'ambiance
en coupe de france le match contre bath
on se rappelle est toujours en football
michael moore pas jouera ce week-end en
championnat après sa belle parenthèse
elle aussi en coupe de france
leur parcours a fait vibrer le
département florane maurepas
malheureusement perdu contre boulogne
billancourt 4 1 au cinquième tour dans
une ambiance sulfureuse vous en souvenez
certainement florane après cette belle
épopée retour au quotidien du
championnat
les morts pas y affronteront à domicile
au stade du bout des clots l'équivalent
et 78 une équipe engluée dans les
profondeurs du championnat excellence
à mon avis le kop de maurepas sera bien
présent pour ce rendez vous il devrait
donc y avoir de l'ambiance ce dimanche à
15 heures au stade du bout des clous
peut-être même que la semaine dernière
lire un match très important en basque
eta 50 basket trappe recevra bons
conseils ce samedi à 20 heures au
gymnase paul mallet en nationale 3 la
rencontre est déjà très important dans
le calendrier des trappistes en
difficulté en championnat avec trois
défaites en trois matches disputés
trappe doit l'emporter contre une équipe
en difficulté qui n'a toujours pas
remporté le moindre match ce sera donc
le match de la peur les joueurs
trappistes compte sur le soutien du
public pour remporter leur première
victoire de la saison
voilà florane vous connaissez tous les
rendez vous sportifs du week-end dans le
département
merci à michael eh bien c'est la fin de
cette édition mais je crois qu'on reste
avec vous que le jour dans quelques
minutes
et oui c'est la première édition de
votre talk show si on parlait sport je
vous conseille de ne pas le rater
vraiment il ya beaucoup de choses à
19h30 on parle de foot mais ma on
parlera également du pg qui risque
d'aller à thiverval grignon viendra je
pense pour pour tous les goûts il y aura
tous les sports qui sont abordés dans
cette émission alors vous l'avez entendu
la première édition du talk show si on
parlait sport c'est aujourd'hui ne ratez
pas la première de michael et demi
d'euros demain comme chaque semaine vous
retrouvez-vous le fridrici pour le 7 8
le journal moi je me retrouvais lundi à
18 heures je vous souhaite une très
bonne soirée et un bon week-end sur
théophile 78